[Musique]
à louer les techniques de l'eau de la
maison lui les flics ripoux leurs
producteurs de vanille transformateurs
vanille à sa ville il ya la région
1depuis eux
seize ans que moi les présents et
représente de 30 % de mon chiffre annuel
donc c'est important et c'est le moyen
de communiquer avec des des politiques
des professionnels et des bons
consommateurs
un tacle à turenne et
simple c'est un peu tant par rapport à
moi depuis 16 ans jura c'est la
troisième année en espèces à continuer
pour ce que ça donne du dynamisme et
s'appelle ça permet de sponsoriser ce
qui viennent et ça permet aussi de
l'économie c'est pour mieux présenter
pour mieux améliorer le papier ni faut
d'ici et là le fait qu un acte où là on
est implanté on a une masse
je n'ai reconnu parmi les autres rats
bravo vous l'été tout timide ou meetic
donc c'est sûr c'est ça fait que tu
viens et savaient pas les la réunion on
voit la réunion
[Musique]